We've been talking a lot about equations that are in the form, y equals mx plus
b. And we've talked about how m here represents the slope of this line, and b is
the y-coordinate of the y-intercept, the place where the graph intersects the
y-axis. When we write an equation in this form, we say that it is written in
slope-intercept form. Since, as we've seen, this let's us just read off the
values of the slope and the y-intercept. Understanding the rule that each of
these constants play in this equation and its graph, can help us get to the
stage of graphing a lot quicker. Let's see if we can figure out how to graph the
equation y equals negative 2x plus 10 without creating an xy table first. Let's
just move straight to the graph. Of course, we have to start by setting up our x
and y axes. Notice here that the scale on either axis is different.
Horizontally, we're counting by ones with each grid but vertically, we're
counting by fours. I just want to make sure we have enough room to show as much
of this line as I want to. One pretty easy way for us to start out would be by
filling in a point that we can find out super easily. So, please begin by
telling me where the y-intercept of this equation is. Please don't forget that
the y-intercept is actually a point, a set of coordinates, not just one number.